how is it doing that hamsters like soda
pop can stuff up to 20 percent of their
body weight into their cheeks for
comparison that's like the average
person carrying around 30 extra pounds
of food or about 120 quarter pounders it
would be a cool party trick but not very
comfortable or let's face it even
possible
that's where hamsters are different but
they don't stuff their faces for parties
or even because they're hungry they do
it to survive in the wild yes there are
actually wild hamsters they eat all
kinds of food leaves shoots veggies and
fruit what they don't consume right away
they store in those cheeks which have
pouches that extend halfway down their
body and expand like a balloon thank
goodness we don't have anything like
that because it would probably look a
little strange but hamsters need to
stuff their faces no matter how goofy it
might look in fact they have to eat
around every two hours to function
normally
but foraging for food this frequently
would make them easy prey
instead they collect food at night and
what they don't store they snack on
along the way so during the day that can
hide from predators and munch on their
hoard and safety and thanks to the
pouches in the cheeks that stockpile can
get enormous hamster burrows have been
found with nearly 200 pounds of stored
food these cheeks also come with special
retractor muscles that help the hamster
stuff itself to maximum capacity if you
ever watch this in action you may notice
that it reorients the food after
plopping it in its mouth
what it's actually doing is angling the
food so it easily slips to the back of
the pouch as more comes in once the food
is well on its way that's when the
retractor muscles come into play when
the pouch stretches the muscles contract
which pushes the food toward the back
preventing it from clogging up pretty
impressive stuff but that's not as
impressive as some of the other things
hamsters can do with their cheeks for
starters some species will hide their
babies inside these pouches to keep them
safe and there are reports that others
can inflate their pouches with air and
use it as a flotation device for
swimming but don't try this at home
only certain wild species do this and we
don't want you to drown your poor
hamster we'd rather have you sit and
enjoy the incredible cuteness of Sodapop
here's a fun fact hamsters can run over
5 miles in a 24-hour period
[Music]